Baruch Spinoza
was a 17th century Dutch philosopher who
tried to reinvent
religion, moving it away from something
based on superstition
and ideas of direct divine
intervention to being a discipline
that was going to be far more impersonal,
quasi scientific
and yet also at times serenely consoling.
Baruch - the word means blessed in
Hebrew,
was born in the Jewish quarter of Amsterdam
in 1632,
a thriving central Jewish commerce in
thought. His ancestors were sephardic Jews
who'd fled the Spanish Peninsula
following the Catholic conspired
expulsion of 1492
Baruch, a studious, highly
intelligent child, received an intensely
traditional Jewish education.
He went to the local Jewish school, the
Yeshiva and followed all the Jewish
High Holidays and rituals
But gradually he began to distance
himself from the faith of his ancestors.
"Although I have been educated from
boyhood in  the accepted beliefs
concerning Scripture",
he later wrote with characteristic
caution, "I have felt bound
in the end to embrace other views". His
fully fleshed-out views
would to be expressed his great work 'The
Ethics', written entirely in Latin
and published in 1677. In The Ethics
Spinoza directly challenged the main
tenets of Judaism in particular
and organized religion in general. God is
not a person who stands outside of nature
there is no one to hear our prayers or
to create miracles
or to punish us for misdeeds. There is no
afterlife
man is not God's chosen creature. The
Bible was only written by
ordinary people. God is not a craftsman or
an architect, nor is he a
King or military strategist who calls
for believers to take up the Holy Sword.
God doesn't see anything, nor does he expect anything.
He doesn't judge. He doesn't even reward the virtuous with the life after death.
Every representation of God as a
person is a projection of the imagination
and everything in the traditional
liturgical calendar is pure superstition
and mumbo-jumbo.
However, despite all this, remarkably,
Spinoza did not declare himself an atheist
He insisted that he remained a staunch
defender of God.
God plays an absolutely central role
in Spinoza's ethics.
But it isn't anything like the God who
haunts the pages of the Old Testament.
Spinoza's God is wholly impersonal and
indistinguishable from what we might
variously called
'nature' or 'existence' or a 'world soul'. God is the universe and its laws
God is reason and truth. God is the
animating force in
everything that is and can be. He is not
in time
and he cannot be individuated.
Spinoza writes:
"Whatever is, is in God and nothing
can exist or be conceived without God."
Throughout his text, Spinoza was keen to
undermine the idea of
prayer. In prayer, an individual appeals
to God
to change the way the universe works. But
Spinoza
argues that this is entirely the wrong
way around. The task of human beings
is to try to understand how and why the
universe works the way it does
and then accept it, rather than protest
at the workings of existence
by sending little messages up into the
sky. As Spinoza put it beautifully
but rather caustically:
"Whoever loves God cannot strive
that God should love him in return".
In other words
only a deeply distorted and
infantile narcissism would lead someone
that wants to believe in God
and then to imagine that this God
would take an interest in bending the
rules of existence
to improve his or her life in some way.
Spinoza was deeply influenced by the
philosophy of the Stoics of ancient
Greece and Rome.
They had argued the wisdom lies not in
protest against how things are
but in continuous attempts to understand
the ways of the world
and then bow down peacefully to
necessity
Seneca, Spinoza's favorite philosopher, had
compared human beings to dogs on a leash
being led by the necessities of life in
a range of directions.
The more one pulls against what's
necessary, the more one is strangled.
And therefore the wise must always
endeavor, to try to understand ahead of time
how things are.
For example what love is like or how
politics works.
And then change their direction
accordingly so as not to be strangled
unnecessarily.
It is this kind of stoic attitude that
constantly pervades Spinoza's philosophy.
To understand God, traditionally means
studying the Bible and other holy texts.
But Spinoza now introduces another idea. The best way to know God
is to understand how life and the
universe work. It's through a knowledge of
psychology, philosophy and the natural
sciences
that one comes to understand God.
In traditional religion believers ask special favors of God. Spinoza proposes instead
that we should understand what God wants
and we can do so in one way above all -
by studying everything that is. By
reasoning
we can exceed to a divine eternal
perspective.
Spinoza made a famous distinction
between two ways of looking at life.
We can either see it egoistically from our
limited point of view.
As he put it: sub specie durationis (under the aspect of time)
or we can look at things globally
and eternally:
sub specie aeternitatis (under the
aspect of eternity).
Our nature means that we'll always be
divided between the two.
Sensual life pulls us towards a time-bound
partial view.
But our reason and intelligence can give us
unique access to another perspective.
It can quite literally allow us - and
here Spinoza becomes beautifully lyrical -
to participate in eternal totality.
Normally we call bad, whatever is bad
for us,
and good whatever increases our power and
advantage. But for Spinoza,
to be truly ethical means rising above
such local concerns.
It might all sound forbidding, but
Spinoza envisaged his philosophy
as a route to a life based on freedom
from guilt,
from sorrow, from pity or from shame.
Happiness involves aligning our will with
that of the universe.
The Universe God has its own projects
and it's our task
to understand rather than rail against
these.
The free person is one conscious of the
necessities that compel us all.
Spinoza writes, the wise man, the person
who understands how and why things are,
possesses eternally true complacency
of spirit.
Needless to say these ideas got Spinoza
into
a very deep trouble. He was excommunicated
from the Jewish community of Amsterdam in 1656
The rabbis issued a censure known as 'cherem'
against the philosopher. It went by the
decree of the
angels and by the commander of the holy man -
we excommunicate, expel, curse
and damn Brauch Spinoza with all the
curses which are written in the book of law
cursed he be by day and cursed be he
by night. Cursed be he when he lies down
and cursed be he when he rises up. Spinoza
was forced to flee Amsterdam
and eventually settled in The Hague,
where he lived quietly and peacefully as
a lens grinder,
and private tutor till his death in 1677.
Spinoza's work was largely forgotten
down the ages.
Hegel took an interest, as did Wittgenstein
and several other twentieth
century philosophers.
But from many perspectives Spinoza's
work constitutes a warning
about failures of philosophy. The ethics
is one of the world's most beautiful
books.
It contains a calming perspective for
storing take on life.
It replaces the God of superstition with
a wise and consoling pantheism.
And yet Spinoza's work failed utterly to
convince any but a few
to abandon traditional religion and to
move towards a rationalist,
wise system of belief. The reasons are in a way
simple and banal. Spinoza failed to
understand,
like so many philosophers before and
since, that what leads people to religion
isn't just reason,
but far more importantly: emotion, belief,
fear
and tradition. People stick with their beliefs
because they like the ritual,
the communal meals,
the yearly traditions, the beautiful
architecture, the music and the lovely
language read out in a sinagoge or
church.
Spinoza's Ethics arguably contains a
whole lot more wisdom than the Bible.
But because it comes without any of the Bible's
supporting structure
it remains a marginal work, studied here
and there at
universities in the West. What the
traditional religion,
that Spinoza thought outmoded in the 1670s,
continues to thrive and convince people. If we're
ever to replace traditional beliefs, we
must remember just how much religion has
helped along
by ritual, tradition, art and a desire to
belong.
All things that Spinoza, despite its
great wisdom,
ignored it as peril in his bold attempt
to replace the Bible.